joe biden he continues to race further
and further to the left to appease his
far left socialist fringe friends and
the d.c
sewer the swamp like ordering a study to
look at the effects of judicial reform
in what is just a step closer towards
packing the court
and turning the judicial branch into an
arm of the democratic socialist party
also developing tonight biden announcing
plans all u.s
troops will be withdrawn from
afghanistan by september the 11th 2021
here to react to this much more south
carolina senator
i'm not sure if tim scott's not the
senior senator though
i don't know he's uh he thinks he's
he was on my radio show he said um
so you see trillions and trillions of
reckless spending
it's not for infrastructure and it's not
for emergency relief
you see amnesty open borders and abusive
cages biden is building then you see
appeasement you see aggression now by
china and russia
and appeasement towards the iranian
mullahs and now pulling out of
afghanistan
what's your overall feeling about right
where we're headed
joe biden's become an incredibly
destabilizing
american president uh he took a border
that was uh pretty calm
and turned it into chaos uh the mideast
had been transformed on trump's watch
where the arabs were working with
israelis
and had iran in a box he's taken iran
and led them out of the box
they're talking about enriching uranium
at 60 percent now which is a direct
threat to the
existence of the state of israel the
russians are challenging
him in the ukraine and now he is
withdrawing forces in afghanistan
against sound military advice to all of
you who are listening you remember where
you're at on september 11
2001. our military told president biden
that if you withdraw all of our forces
al qaeda and isis will come roaring back
afghanistan would disintegrate into
civil war and we can avoid
all of that by having three to five
thousand american forces
making sure that isis and al qaeda never
come back to hurt us
he rejected that advice afghanistan is
going to deteriorate pretty rapidly al
qaeda and isis are going to come back
he's paving the way for another 9 11. i
think joe biden on foreign policy has
been completely incompetent
and destabilizing what he's done with
the iranians is a threat to everything
we've accomplished in the mideast
i just hope and pray that i'm wrong but
i know what was going to i knew what was
going to happen in iraq
afghanistan is going to be worse let me
ask you this
there's never been a major political
party that has turned this radical
new green deal reckless spending all the
things that that we
we talk about now if my political
instincts if i learned anything in 33
years of doing this i would tell you
that there's going to be a major
backlash
and the big first test whether or not
i'm right will be in 2022 you couldn't
pick a more perfect
bellwether map for the u.s senate i
think the republicans have a good chance
of taking control of the house that
would be good
but in the senate you got florida you
got georgia you got north carolina
you've got new hampshire
you've got ohio you've got arizona
you've got wisconsin
uh those are all the states that matter
for 2024 but you got senate races in
2022 your thoughts
on what the agenda should be moving
forward and who should lead it
well i think president trump is the
leader of the party and i'm hoping he
will come out
fairly soon with an american first
agenda that
includes simple things like finish the
wall
and make sure that we're safe when it
comes to foreign policy
keep the pressure on iran don't take it
off so i hope we can come out with an
agenda led by president trump that will
unite the republican party
but this idea of court packing
destabilizes the court
they're talking about expanding the
number of supreme court justices
justice breyer a democratic appointee
and justice ginsburg said it'd be a bad
idea just imagine every time you change
power in washington
you change the number of justices on the
court it becomes a political football
he's let the iranians run wild he's
given them
you know a second lease on life he's
withdrawing our forces in afghanistan
that would pave the way for another 9
11.
he's taken a border that was pretty damn
secure and created chaos
i think all this is going to be on the
ballot in 2022 if we get our act
together as republicans
we're going to come roaring back all
right senator lindsey graham